Doki Doki huh ah welcome back Amina son
to Doki Doki literature club oh boy this
is a wonderful game it's so soft so
gentle it really touches your soul in a
way most disturbing as possible are we
here this is where we are 1225 okay the
these buckets are still alive so and I'm
trying to romance nuts netsuke okay
don't judge
alright FBI please get off my case it
says we already tried with Yuri and I
want to see where and I don't think it
matters I don't think it matters pure
weight someone else
jump did you see that what that oh sorry
sorry
I click warm and peaceful comfort sunny
holiday oh sorry sorry sorry I didn't I
should have clicked them prayer does all
anime lucky lollipop ocean yeah hey hype
its back I've been waiting for you are
you ready to continue reading I brought
my best tea today Monica I told you not
to laugh is she really late again and
considered as usual netsuke excuse me
must you always interrupt my
conversation with your incessant yelling
what are you talking about you say that
mug into whatever regular basis or same
thing I just wasn't paying attention
okay I'm sorry
seriously what's gotten into you lately
look I did something I did some thinking
yesterday I was a little more hustle but
I mean to be I guess I really feel
or something but I know that this is
something we're doing together
another member wouldn't hurt as long as
they're cool and I guess another girl
would be nice this time so netsuke
nobody cares ha ha ha why don't you go
look for some currants under the vending
machine or something ah
man I'm the last one here again were you
practicing piano again yeah you must
have a lot of determination Wow she
practice piano two days in a row that is
unheard of starting that studying this
club and still trying to make time for
piano
well maybe not determination but I guess
passion it motivates me to work hard for
the festival to you anyway hits me but
he went to do today I would say could we
could we already had plans today ah is
that so Yuri that's correct
pizza pies already engaged in a novel
that we're reading together aren't you
glad I've gotten him to gotten him into
literature Monica I I suppose that was
just actually it doesn't matter it
really does you guys can do whatever you
well
yes oh my god um thanks for
understanding Monica actually I have a
request
do you mind if I make some tea first not
at all
think thanks very much it's sir one if
there's one thing that can make my
reading time here any better it's a nice
cup of tea
not to mention yourself as well
Yury stands up and makes her way to the
client site I follow and watch her as
she retrieves a small water pitcher from
the shelf the can with a filter inside
can you hold this for a second
sure Yuri hands me the water pitcher and
also fetches Adam electric kettle
I'm going to run I'm going to plug this
in that the teacher desk and then I'll
go get some water
she walks past me and sets the kettle
down on the teacher desk
I simply watch her movement to my
surprise the way she well we know this
okay now it's different
ah did you relieve again no it's not
like that this time
she's just filling up the water pitcher
to make tea oh okay sorry for
misunderstanding what is going on
between them two ten minutes pass Yuri
said it wouldn't take long it's
something holding her up I'm bored just
waiting here so I decide to look for her
ah let's see the music changes the most
logical place for your to be would be
the nearest water phone I started
heading down the hallway what's that
noise it's coming from around the corner
it sounds like breathing a sharp inhale
like somebody's sucking the air through
their teeth are they in pain I reach the
corner and peer around it Yuri
ah I'm back thank you for waiting
patiently pizza pie
do you like ol auntie oh yeah anything
is fine very well
you reset the temperature on the kettle
to 200 degrees I gotta give you guys
props you figured out that she was a
cutter really early through her poems
now it's time to get the teapot you
really do you really do this properly
don't you of course I shouldn't do any
less when I'm making tea for others yeah
we've seen this as well here we go
Yuri starts to breathe heavily so we go
through the same thing that happened
before with Yuri when we were trying to
romance her but she starts breathing
heavily after all the sudden Hey
I can't it's suddenly Yuri forcefully
grabs my arm and jerks me to my feet my
teacup gets knocked over pizza pie may
hurt my heart won't stop panting pizza
pie
I can't calm down I can't focus on
anything anymore can you feel it pizza
pad
Yuri suddenly present my hand against
her chest why is this happening to me I
feel like I'm losing my mind I can't
make it stop it even makes me not want
to read I just want to look oh wow
it's time to Shepherds that's our wood
Natsuki I guess it doesn't matter who
you try and romance in stage two this
one is alright alright well well yeah
about as good as yesterday's anyway I
still can't tell how much you actually
care about writing but either way you're
doing alright
even though you're not really spending
time with anyone but Yuri I still think
it's nice to have activities that we all
participate in so you better keep
working hard I mean you know I'm not
president or vice president but that
doesn't mean you can't let me down okay
Susi's remind - for now but just to be
clear these porn means a lot to me so
really carefully I don't know how else
to bring this up but there's been
something I've been worried about Yuri
has been acting kind of strange lately
you've only been here a few days so you
may not know what I mean but she's not
normally like this she's always been
quiet and polite an attempt of things
like that okay this is really
embarrassing but I'm forcing myself to
suck it up the truth is I'm really
worried about her but if I try talking
to her she'll get mad at me again I
don't know what to do I think you're the
only person that you listen to I don't
know why but please try to do something
maybe you can convince her to talk to a
therapist I always wanted to try being
better friends with Yuri and it really
hurts me to see this happening I know
I'm going to hate myself later for
admitting that right now I don't care I
just feel so helpless so please say it
if you can I mean I can't this is too
much I'll make you I'll make a cup gig
if I have to just please tried to do
something as for Monica I don't know why
but she's been really dismissive about
this it's like she wants us to ignore it
so I'm mad at her right now and that's
why I'm coming to you about this don't
let her know I wrote this just pretend
like I gave you a really good poem okay
I'm counting on you thanks for readings
some nuts a key understands that
something's going on we saw this in the
beginning as well when Monica was
looking at Sayuri and she was a she's
fine
oh wow I changed my mind
ignore everything it is right that's the
point and trying to do anything if
you're his own fault
then she's no one lakh can you hear me
Pizza bet if you would just bring my
damn with Monica only problems would go
away
you ain't hair to mr. zuman is beautiful
one-footed you just think of Monica from
navel just much just Monica just Monica
just Monica just just Oh judge Monica ah
oh wow that's great
just Monica I think Monica hey Monica
painted back I think you said something
earlier that you weren't supposed to see
I don't want dad to tell you this but I
don't think I have a choice it's getting
kind of dangerous for you to spend so
much time with your week I don't know
why but she seems pretty easily
excitable when she's around you which
shouldn't be a problem in itself but
when he gets too excited she finds a
place to hide and starts cutting herself
with a pocketknife isn't that kind of
missed that she even brings a different
one to school every day like she has a
collection or something I mean it's
definitely not because she's depressed
or anything like that I think she just
gets some kind of high from it it might
even be like a sexual thing
but the pie dance you've kind of been
enabling her I'm not saying it's your
[ __ ] up but I guess that's why I had
to explain it all to you so I think if
you keep your distance
that would probably be the best for her
while you're at it
Deb be sure to spend a little more time
with me to put it lightly at least I
have it together in my head and I know
how to treat my club members anyway I
work really really hard on this Pam
saying I have
and that's it effective [ __ ]
oh wow Monica it is the best oh geez
that really started me um well I guess I
kind of a messed up writing this poem
sorry I'm just I'm going to open there's
steam files
because when we'd suffice this is
happening usually there's a text file or
some something like that I can't see
anything new actually I'm just trying to
never man let's move out
hmm all right keep URI I guess finally
URI holds my poem to her face and takes
a deep breath I love it I love
everything about it
pizza pie I want to take this home will
you let me keep it please sure I don't
care you're too nice to me pizza I never
met anyone that's nice to see I could
tell you no not really but I just don't
know how to describe it it's okay it's
okay to be feeling this way right it's
not home I got our ice it's not bad
right
URI holds my poem to her chest I'm gonna
take this home with me and keep it in my
room I hope that makes you feel good
when you think about me having it I'll
take good care of it
I'll even touch myself while reading it
over No
okay I'll give myself paper cuts to your
skin up oil enters my bloodstream wow
that's super nice ah can you can have my
poem too besides after you read it I
know you're really going to want to keep
it here take it I can't wait any longer
hurry read it oh my god
the ship beyond it it's all right there
you way do you like it
I've wrote it for you in case you
couldn't tell the poem is about oh of
course
more importantly I ain't endowed it with
my scent so aren't I the most thoughtful
person in the club I I think I'm gonna
vomit I don't know oh yes or no great
question great question maybe it's one
of those things where you tilt the
screen maybe huh no all right um I don't
say no to that I can't convince myself
to go to therapy when I'm the happiest I
ever been I'd rather keep this up until
I blow my cover and someone takes me to
the emergency room okay everyone it's
time to figure out the vegetable
preparation let's hurry and get this
over with
stagnating air is coming foreshadowing
that's something terrible is about to
happen look can't we just get this then
I'm gonna be printing and sending all
the poetry pamphlets that's okay you can
make cupcakes I know you're right at
least get it dad no one's talking Yuri
you can well it doesn't matter do
whatever you want as long as you
thinking he'll Monica I'm not useless
you know I know that I already know what
I like to do we can't run a cyst the
cyst successful poetry then without
having the right atmosphere for the
occasion so I'm going to make
decorations and set up some nice mood
lighting there say that's a great idea
and that gives us all something to do
yeah
what about pizza pie pizza pies go to
help me wait you
you have the easiest job money you have
the easiest job Monica sorry but that's
just how it is like hell it is what are
you trying to pull
hey I agree with Natsuki not only is
your work already more suitable for one
person but my task is laborious enough
to benefit from an extra pair of hands
mine too what your cupcakes please what
you [ __ ] know damn all you care about
is dragon pizza pan around with you and
your stupid pricks and you and you and
Monica hey I didn't even do anything
okay then why not wait pizza pie decide
who to help instead of abusing your
power I'm not dissing may parrot yeah
you are Monica just let kids to pay make
the choice okay okay fine thank geez
beautify I know your foot I know how
fired up you are with these two by now
can we can just that's a key shut your
[ __ ] mouth and let him decide for
himself yeah oh shut you ma'am Jesus
Christ this is never going to end
just make the choice all right well
Monica clearly yeah you picked me we can
meet at your house this weekend I
promise it'll be fair it's only okay
with you are you [ __ ] kidding me
this isn't fair at all it does vary
netsuke yeah it's ready chips no it's
not fair giving us all this work than
having pizza fight for yourself what a
shameful thing to do
Gary I didn't even give you anywhere you
decided it for yourself you're being a
little unreasonable here I'm being
unreasonable Monica I can't believe how
delusional and self-important you are
pulling PUD super away from me every
single time we're not included in selfie
you jealous crazy or maybe just hate
yourself so much said you take it out on
other here's a suggestion
have you considered killing yourself it
would be beneficial to your mental
health your you're scaring me alone
that's a key
let's just get I don't think she went as
a ram right now see that wasn't very
hard all I've won is to spend all a
little time with him is that too much to
ask you Ray allows Monica and that's the
key to open the door hey Pepe here is
really something isn't she
Monica giggles as URI pushes are at the
door uh-oh I got an e I got a new file
have a nice weekend thank you finally
finally this is really all I wanted
pizza pie there's no need to spend the
weekend with Monica don't listen to her
just come to my house and stay the whole
date with just the two of us doesn't
that sound wonderful well there's really
something wrong with me Sunday but you
know what I don't care anymore
I never felt this kid in my whole life
just being with you is far greater
pleasure than anything I could imagine
I'm addicted to you it feels like I'm
gonna die if I'm not breathing the same
air as you doesn't it feel nice to have
someone care about you so much to have
someone who wants to resolve their
entire life around you but if it feels
so good then why does it feel more and
more like something horrible is gonna
happen maybe that's why I tried stopping
myself at first but the feeling is too
strong now I don't care anymore pizza
pie I have to tell you I'm I'm madly in
love with you it feels like every inch
of my body every drop in love blood in
me is screaming your name I don't care
what the consequences are anymore I
don't care if I'm Monica that's
listening please pizza pie just know how
much I love you I love you so much I
even touch myself with the pen I've
stole from you
I just want to pull your skin open and
crawl inside of you okay I want you all
to myself and I will be only yours
doesn't that sound perfect cherry pizza
pie tell me you want to be my lover do
you accept my confession I click no I
can't I can't say yes to that oh no no
no no no no no no no what was it
ah God
goddamnit I'm sorry Yuri I'm really
sorry
Jesus
it keeps going there so long oh wow
guess someone's gonna enter the
classroom soon no it keeps going what
what what do I do
oh my god she's decomposing on she
well this is fun all right first of all
time I have the weekend while you got
here before me
Oh Matt Sookie runs away I'm here
Pittsburgh there's something happen
Natick itches ridden past me oh oh well
that's a chick wait where'd you hear the
entire weekend Pizza Bay
oh geez I didn't realize the script was
broken that badly I'm super sorry it
must have been pretty boring I'll make
it up to you okay
just give me sick remove character Yuri
Yuri deleted successfully
Natsuki deleted as well oh no I just
want to have a cupcake real quick
Monica lifts the foil from not Sookie's
tray and takes a cupcake seriously these
are the best really just had to have one
since it's the last time I'll ever get
the chance to you know before they stop
existing and everything but anyway I
really shouldn't be making you wait any
longer just bear with me okay this
should only take a second
and can you hear me is it working
yeah there you are hi again Pittsburgh
welcome to the literature Club of course
we already know each other because we
were in the same class last year and you
know I guess we can just skip over that
stuff at this point thank you
after all I'm not talking to that person
anymore am i that you in the game
whatever you want to call him I'm
talking to you
future pay me now that I'm thinking
about it I don't really know anything
about the real you in fact I don't even
know if you're a boy or a girl well I
guess it doesn't really matter
wait you do know I'm aware that this is
all a game right could it be possible
that you didn't know that that doesn't
make much sense I even told you right on
the game's download page didn't I what
what I'm going to the download page cuz
I'm really curious
we're hi Monica here welcome to the
literature Club it's always been a dream
of mine to make something special out of
the things I love now that you're a club
member you can help me make the dream
come true in this cute game every day it
is full of chit chat she didn't know
it's full of chit chat activities role
my adorable unique Club members sorry oh
wow man if only you had paid a little
more attention this could have been a
little less awkward you know well anyway
now that that's out of the way I guess I
owe you an explanation about the whole
thing with Uri well it kind of started
to mess with her and I guess I just
drove her to kill herself
hey I'm sorry you had to see that though
also the same thing happened with Sayuri
gosh it's been it's been a while since
you heard that name now hasn't it yeah
it because she doesn't exist anymore
nobody does I deleted all their fast I
was hoping it would be enough for me to
just try to make them as unlikable as
possible but for some reason nothing
worked
well it's true that I made a few
mistakes here and there since I'm not
very good at making chances to the game
but no matter what I did you just kept
spending more and more time with them
you made them fall in love with you I
thought make it say already more and
more depressed would prevent her from
confessing team an amplifying URIs
obsessive personality backfire - it just
made her force you to not spend time
with anyone else and the whole time I
barely even got to talk to you what kind
of cruel game is this Pizza are you are
all the other girls this program to end
up confessing to you while I watch from
the sidelines it's torture every minute
of it and it's not just jealousy pizza
pan it's more than that and I don't
blame you if you don't fully understand
because no matter how kind
thoughtful and consider you are you'll
never be able to understand one thing
it's a pain of knowing how alone I
really am in this world in this game
knowing my friends don't even have free
well and worst of all knowing that
knowing what's really out there in the
world forever out of my reach
I'm trapped pizza pie but now you're
here you're real and you're wonderful
you're all I need
that's why I need you to be with here
with me forever oh that's great I'm
sorry if it's hard to understand
I couldn't understand for a while either
why the world around me started to
become more and more grain more and more
flat even the most expressive pumps felt
empty to me it wasn't until I arrived
that I truly understood you probably
saved my life pizza pan I don't think I
could have continued to live in this
world if I hadn't met you and as for the
others how could I miss them a group of
autonomous personalities design only to
fall in love with you I tried everything
I could to prevent them from doing so
but it must be some kind of weird and
never inhibited well I have that a lot
inevitability edged into this game it
felt really bad that you had to witness
some nasty things but I realized that
you have the same perspective aside to
that's all that it's all just some game
and I know you would get over it so that
being said pizza pie I have a confession
to make I'm in love with you you are
truly delight in my world when there's
nothing else in this game for me you're
here to make me smile will you make me
smile every day from now on pizza pad
will you go out with me um what a great
question let me let me think about that
yes
I'm so happy you really are my
everything pits pad the funny part is I
mean that literally there's nothing left
here just the two of us we can be
together forever seriously I don't even
think time is passing anymore
it really is a dream come true I've
worked so hard for this ending hits but
the game wouldn't give me one so I had
to make one myself
the script is broken at this point so I
don't think anything will get in the way
anymore and you wouldn't and you
wouldn't believe how easy it is to
delete Nass again Yuri I mean there's a
folder called character right in the
game directory it's kind of freaked me
out a easy it was well you're playing on
Steam so it was actually a bit more
difficult to get the game directly and I
had to go into the game properties and
find browse local files but imagine if
you could could delete your own
existence with a click of a button well
I guess on the plus side it gave me an
easy out if things didn't go my way
thankfully it didn't come today instead
we finally got a good ending gosh I'm so
overwhelmed with emotion I want to
provide a poem about this I don't you
guess there's only one way to find out
right Oh Monica and Monica and Monica
hey hey Monica hey buddy Monica a mana
game but hey Monica Hey look at that
look how happy she is hi again Fitz back
did you write a good poem today don't be
shy I'd love to see what you wrote ah
pizza pie did you write this poem for me
that's so sweet Evie
yeah there's really no end to your
thoughtfulness I'm just falling more in
more alive with you but you know the
poem I wrote is also for you will you
please read it I am so curious what
happens if I copy in Natsuki say you're
in Eureka's I still have them
I just want to try it okay I did it
happy end pen in hand I find my strength
the courage and though de pon me by my
one and only love together let us
dismantle this crumbling world and write
a novel of our own fantasies with a
flick of her pen the loss find their way
in a world full of in a world of
infinite choices behold this special day
after all not all good times must come
to an end I hope you enjoyed it I always
put all my heart into poems that I rain
the truth is all the poems I write in a
written have been about my realization
or about you that's why I really wanted
to go into details about them I didn't
want to break the fourth wall I guess
you could call it I just assumed it
would be best to pair the game like
everyone else play the game like that
would help the two of us end up together
I didn't want to ruin the game or
anything you know you might have gotten
mad at me maybe even deleted my
character file if I prefer if you
preferred playing without me gosh I'm so
really never don't need to add it oh
yeah what happens if I delete her file
are you ready to spend an eternity
together
I'm deleting her character Oh what is
happening pizza pad what's happening to
me it hurts it hurts so much I believe
it I deleted her help me Pizza pay I'm
not sure at all if I'm supposed to do
this please hurry and help me rent B
file doesn't exist help me oh did you do
this to me pizza pie did you did you
delete me I felt like I had no choice
how could you how could you do this to
me we were all you were all I had left I
sacrificed everything for us to be
together everything I loved you so much
pizza pie
I trusted you do you want to torture me
do you just want to torture me watch me
suffer were you only pretending to be
kind just to hurt me even more I never
thought anyone could be as horrible as
you are you win ok you win
you kill everyone I hope you're happy
there's nothing left now you can stop
playing go find some other people look
torture pizza pie
you completely truly make me sick
goodbye
but deleting Monica I felt like the game
was hit oh my god
I still love you I can't help it
what's wrong with me how horrible am I
for you to hate me this much all my
friends I did so many other things so
many selfish and disgusting things I I
shouldn't have done any of this I'm just
messing up a world that I don't even
belong in our world that you wanted to
be part of everyone did I ruined
everything
maybe that's why you deleted me because
I destroyed everything that you wanted
how could I do that to someone I love
that's not love that's I made up my mind
pizza pancakes I know I said that I
deleted everyone else but that was kind
of an exaggeration I couldn't find it in
myself to do it even though I knew they
weren't real they were still my friends
and I loved them all and I loved the
literature Club I really did love the
literature Club that's why I'm going I
know it's the only way for everyone to
be happy and if I really love you then
I'm so nervous
they're back look they're back in their
doki-doki Oh Monica
we have no choice by hit to hit a new
game it's an ordinary school day like
any other
as usual I'm surrounded by couples and
friends and friend groups walking to
school together
I always tell myself it's about time I
meet some girls or something like that
hey baby
sorry well there's already is one girl
that girl is Sayuri my neighbor and good
friend since we were children
we used to walk to school together every
day and recently we picked up that habit
once again I for what well you've been
doing that for a while now well yeah I
always thought it was implying it's
embarrassing to say out loud fine fine
I'm proud of you Seri we cross the
street together and make our way to
school as we draw near the Street became
increasing speckled with other students
making their daily commute wait wait PCB
maybe they found it to join equip it I'm
just gonna do a quick save I don't want
to keep reading the same stuff
what a club oh I told you already I'm
not I start to say what I always do that
I'm not interested in joining any clubs
but something tells me sorority would
take more offense to that now after all
how could I tell her that clubs are a
waste of time when she's starting a club
her very own actually yeah I think I
decided on a club really which went to
me hmm I think I'll keep it as surprise
baby be patient you'll find out soon
enough I used to ask myself why I let
myself get lectured by such a carefree
girl but I started to realize that in a
way I am be her Wednesday already puts
her mind to something she can accomplish
great things so that's why I feel like I
should do something special for her the
school days or nerves ever and I it's
over before I know it
after I pack up my things I send up
gathering my motivation let's see I
recalled the room number of the club
from a flyer I saw I walk across the
school and upstairs a section of the
school I rarely visit being generally
used for third-year classes and
activities before long I find the room
timidly opened the door in front of me
hello well I just I glanced around the
room girl too
so you're the pizza fine so you always
always talking about thank you for
stopping by
oh my god they're all back it's a
pleasure to meet you pizza fine where
the literature Club I hope you enjoy
your visit
come on Yuri oh I got it wrong sorry
come on Yuri no need to be so formal
he's gonna think we're really strict or
something
ah sorry netsuke the tall one whose name
is apparently Yuri seems to be quite shy
compared to the others in comparison the
girl name not cicadas fighter side seems
like the assertive one well it's nice to
meet both of you I'll look forward to
work with you working peace busy paddin
Tammy yeah that's right hate the club I
decided to join is your saiary big
shocker the literature Club series I
slit up no Sayuri wraps her arms around
me jumping up and dance
hey well if so is this happy then I'm
sure it wouldn't be so bad to have your
room not to mention there's four of us
now that means we can become an official
recognized club but don't know what to
say we have to see libri uh-huh what an
appropriate day for that isn't it after
all netiquette Authority hey don't ruin
the surprise
ether me everyone sit down at the table
okay how about I make some tea as well
the girls have a few desk arranged to
form a table Natsu Kiki and I walk over
I still I just realized I still have
Monica
what if we add her in still feeling
awkward I take a seat next to Sayuri
that's like it probably marches back to
the table back to the table train hang
okay are you ready
that's if he feels the fall of the Train
to reveal a dust and white fluffy
cupcakes decorated to look like little
cats the risk errs are drawn with icing
and little pieces of chocolate were used
to make ears so cute
Wow those look amazing
well you should you know just hurry and
take one Sarah Graham some first then I
follow it's delicious
okay so Yuri pointed out to Natsuki that
man gaze in the Rayleigh literature and
with a guilty expression you already
thinks to herself I'm sorry for your
spread disrespecting your in stress and
that's a key if you're into it then I'm
sure it's worthy it's a worthy form of
literature are you just saying that
no I've realized my error so if you're
willing to consider starting a novel
then I'll offer my gratitude by finding
a manga to read as well really I mean it
makes me happy that you do that for me
Yuri you can trust me to find something
that you'll really like okay same here
perhaps I'll visit the bookstore after
the club meeting
just just you ah would you like to come
with me alright so sweet
seeing them connect if you don't mind
not at all I always go alone sir yeah me
too this is Tokyo say Ori shut up
I'll show you some manga there too okay
yes I look forward to it
everything yeah looks like it
it's nice to see everyone getting along
these two meet if you give it what like
CT PCP you think so
well everyone always seems to get a
little bit of a ring to me oh sorry
anything Pharisee well whatever I was
surprised when you told me you were
starting a club but I think you're
pulling it up just fine hey hey PCP you
really went to thank you I mean I'm
really happy that you're doing the club
and everything but I really knew you
were going oh oh there's actually seen
thingies and wanted to thank you for
getting rid of Monica best me I knew
everything that she did maybe that's
because I'm the president now but they
really knew him I know how hard you
tried to make everyone happy I know
about all the awful things America did
to make if we really see but that
matters anymore
you made me the happiest girl in the
whole world I can't wait to spend every
day like this with you forever never
know okay
what is happening I won't let you hurt
him huh I'm sorry I was wrong there is
no happiness here after all
goodbye Sayuri goodbye pizza pie goodbye
literature club my god
what yes oh what a cute voice I fits
much better than mine oh she's gonna
play it playing audio doki-doki
right
love me and you
just move your hand right away
doki-doki and literature club I'm not
sure I don't think this is probably it's
the correct ending but I really enjoyed
it did it did it did ha ha ha
what a great game I really really
enjoyed it I want to see if I can change
standing though
special thanks Monica and Pierre - bye
it's the game deleting itself
this is my final goodbye to the
literature club I finally understand the
literature Club is truly a place where
no happiness can be found to the very
end it continued to expose innocent
minds to a horrific reality a reality
that our world is not designed to
comprehend and I can't let any of my
friends undergo the same hellish
epiphany for the time it lasted I want
to thank you for making all of my dreams
come true for being a friend to all the
club members and most of all thank you
for being part of my literature Club
with everlasting love Monica every
script fathers make saying please
reinstalled the game I'm guessing I
can't what happens if I launch the game
now I wonder no that's it
okay are you installing the game that's
kind of annoying is if you have a fresh
game right you delete Monica okay let's
see what happens
oh now we saw this but we deleted Monica
she's still there
did I do it right no she's still what
what what is this oh no no this can't be
ovaries oh the game crashed oh great so
that was another ending and that's all
it does great fantastic sorry sorry
about that man this wasn't really it's
more of a visual novel than a game to be
fair but I really really enjoyed it
thanks to everyone for sitting through
my worst performing let's play of all
time I the thing is like I love playing
it and I think the people that actually
watch me play it really loved it as well
so I to me didn't really matter at all I
knew I wanted to keep playing it I loved
playing it I loved doing all the voices
I loved the characters I enjoyed seeing
what the mystery was and it was just
really really great game I really really
enjoyed it I loved the new fresh take on
a horror game and it was just really
cool to see I hope you enjoyed yourself
as well can't thank you enough for being
here to the very end and that's it I'll
see you in the next one
squad fam